like my brother worked for mcdonald's
and uh
when i turned 16 i really wanted the
[ __ ] xbox one so i was like okay i'm
gonna get a job mcdonald's yeah
you pay like four pound ten an hour
which is like five dollars i thought
like maybe
five dollars fifty um and yeah i [ __ ]
hated it and uh
i remember my brother telling me he was
like yeah you're gonna get sick of
mcdonald's food really fast
and i was like six months and i'm like i
[ __ ] love this food stuff
you'd get to make your own like you
weren't supposed to
but like the managers were like you
could have this like
yeah yeah you can so you could basically
make your own burger right so i used to
just make like the
like in the uk we have like fried
chicken sandwiches like yeah like fancy
ones
they used like the like they're like a
better meat i mean still all [ __ ]
awful
but i would just [ __ ] put like a
handful of [ __ ] bacon and just shove
it on
that was like the best part right and
then you could get like meals for like
half price but
everything else was [ __ ] awful at
mcdonald's everything was awful like
the people the people were the worst
part man they were just like
the workers or the customers workers the
workers oh really yes because i just
didn't get on with any of them
and they were all you know like not to
be mean but a lot of the ones that i
worked with were like people that like
yeah i wouldn't be friends with when
whenever i go to a mcdonald's and i see
like an employee smiling i'm like
he's suspicious yeah yeah yeah who's he
murdered today so some some
like orange is suss right now you know i
remember i legitimately got like
i i got like put i had to go and sit in
the like [ __ ] put on like detention
for like 20 minutes because at the
mcdonald's because i was working
on the [ __ ] like making the chicken
burgers and the burgers i was making the
burgers and they told me off for not
smiling
and i said i said i said why do i have
to smile when making burgers
and they looked at me like why did you
ask that question and they told me to go
and take a break for 20 minutes like a
george orwell novel
i was like dystopia everyone has to
smile what do you mean why am i not
[ __ ] smiling mate i'm making a
[ __ ] burger what do you mean
i couldn't believe i was furious yeah
it's like it's like they're at home they
make their own sandwiches like [ __ ] i
forgot to smile i can't believe it
and so i was like 16 one time and the
the one time when i was like i [ __ ]
hate it here
was when uh they were talking to me and
these dudes were like 25
and they were bragging to me like both
of them were bragging to me about how
they were going to
the party in the school next to me right
like 16 year olds
yeah and i was like so you went to a
party full of 16 year olds and they're
like yeah it was sick and i'm like
why why did you go to a party full of 16
year olds you're 25 and they're like oh
i want to get with the girls i'm like
what am i in this in the uk it's
legal for 16. but i was still like what
yeah but still
yeah but still and the only nice people
there were the ones above 40 but
everyone near my age was just the
[ __ ] worst
and every time i had to go and train
someone uh so i was there for like three
months and after three months
you're ready to train people you're a
[ __ ] mcdonald's veteran because
you've lasted more than ninety percent
of the [ __ ] employees
no joke because i i i believe that yeah
because
they hired some they they over hire
because they know that people are going
to
like leave yeah like so i was teaching
this one guy
and he was clearly like just like not
getting it
you didn't want to get it and he could i
could tell he was like yeah i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna listen to this so about
two hours into his shift of me teaching
him
uh he goes i'mma get a smoke break she
never came back
he just left he just straight up left
you're like he never came back
and then i had to do the whole shift on
my own then doing all this [ __ ] and i
was like i went to my boss and i'm like
uh
so uh yeah he didn't come back he just
went for a smoke break you know
i just smoked about two hours ago he
just he just pulled like the dad
what do i do and they're like oh you've
got to work on your own and i'm like
what what do you mean
what do you mean and uh although so like
i got a
for one another time i was making uh
it's the same guy actually it was the
first hour of teaching him
and when you're what was the entire
timeline how long did he work here that
you had to teach him for three hours and
a half and he went for a smoke break
but i had to keep working because uh and
i asked okay this is really bad and i
honestly i could just [ __ ] sued
mcdonald's for this yeah
so um when we were this really [ __ ]
hot oil it's
like 400 degrees from ridiculous fry oil
yeah yeah it's ridiculously hot
and this [ __ ] next to me i was like
yeah just gently put it in you know
next to me while i was showing him i'm
like yeah so put the chicken nuggets in
here and he [ __ ] slams them in
right oil went all over my hand right
yeah and then i asked could i go and put
it under cold water to my boss and they
were like no you got to keep working
and i'm like what so i'm here [ __ ]
like crying of pain
making these [ __ ] burgers right and
and then and don't forget to smile
right don't forget to smile i have a
third degree burn
so like i'm about an hour later it's
finally my time to get a break right
and i'm eating my burger and you can see
my my hand is just bright pink and like
blistered
and the other manager because of course
there's multiple managers yeah there's
one mcdonald's
the other manager comes in and is
mortified he's like what the [ __ ] is
that
he's like what happened and i'm like oh
i just spilled oil on it and
he's like why didn't you put your hand
under water i was like oh cause the
other manager said i couldn't
and bear man i was like 16 so yeah you
know i should have known that i could
have been like no [ __ ] you i'm putting
my hand in the water yeah
when you're 16 if the boss tells you to
do what you're told
right of course yeah so and then he was
mortified and the other boss got in
so much [ __ ] and they apologized to me
profusely and then they like were like
yeah it's okay you don't come to work
tomorrow it's all paved and i'm like wow
that's so nice of them
but i realized at the time they were
just like hoping i wouldn't [ __ ] try
and sue them
right because i could have like i could
have easily i should have honestly i
think that's like some serious oh
problem yeah and then finally when i
quit uh i quit prematurely because uh
i was just done my manager was a total
[ __ ] the store owner was horrible she
hated dudes
like she would always be so nice to the
women
working there and i you know and then
whenever i guided anything wrong you get
absolutely like [ __ ] on
you know i'm taking i know i'm talking
so much sorry it's the last time i just
it took me like eight months to realize
what he realized in two hours
right
you know what the the reduced money on
the meals just doesn't work
because okay you gotta admit right i was
the [ __ ] king when school and i was
like you want a lunch break
i get half price off mcdonald meals do
you want to who wants to come here
i remember the cool kids in school well
whoever worked at the coolest place and
could get like the best discount yeah
the discount so whoever worked in the
[ __ ] gaming store right they were the
king
yeah like yeah cause i could bring my
mate and lunch i'm like we can get a
whole mcdonald's meal for two pounds
whole meal any size you want treat
yourself treats yeah it was great i mean
i
was i could have got fat so anyway i'm
working like a shift right and then
i'd actually have been training to be a
lifeguard i did all the staff and i
applied to be a lifeguard
and you know when you work some for a
place you've got to put down a reference
yeah i've never have you ever had this
where they actually contact the
reference
no i've never had that so i just thought
it was like a myth i thought it was like
a bluff it was like come on name someone
name someone what a [ __ ] day to call
them there's someone who will interred i
dare you
yeah so they actually [ __ ] called my
mcdonald's whilst i was working my shift
right so they they do it and they come
in like uh so connor
are you looking for other employment and
i'm like uh
why like what do you mean like because
we just got a call from uh
the council asking uh for a reference
you'd be a lifeguard what's up with that
you didn't tell us
and i was like in my head i'm like why
do i have to tell you yeah like [ __ ] you
you pay me four dollars an hour like
what do i owe you
yeah what are they gonna be like you can
check out but you can never leave yeah
and i was like oh well yeah i mean i was
looking for a better job
and they [ __ ] like flipped a switch
when i said a better job they were like
what do you mean a better job
i think mcdonald's is a bad job and i
was like well i mean yes
look here i'm looking around and i'm
like
[Music]
one of what surprised me is like how
little self-awareness they seem to have
over there right because the thing is
right
no i don't want to be i don't want to
[ __ ] on some of these guys because i
know i've met some managers at
mcdonald's are generally like super nice
guys
they have such like you know they
understand like it's a mcdonald's yeah
yeah but the managers at my mcdonald's
they were like
are you trying to say like you're trying
to say my my managerial job is like a
joke
like and i'm in my head i'm kind of like
yeah
yes actually did you see the food thing
safety thing we had to fill out online
that was
that was a joke come on it's like don't
[ __ ] on the lettuce obviously don't [ __ ]
on the lettuce
so the manager's really pissed off right
and the store man the store owner is
coming in 10 minutes
and he's like i want you to talk to the
store and explain yourself
when he comes in i'm like are you
serious i'm 16.
so they really did not want to make you
leave they really like [ __ ] put me
through the ringer dude for these four
dollars an hour dude like can you
believe that
so you want your ex and my mom wondered
why i [ __ ] hated working here and she
was like no you're just over
exaggerating connor and i'm like no it
was awful
so the manager the store owner comes in
right
and uh they make me go and talk to her
in front of customers and she's rinsing
me in front of these customers like
like shouting at me in front of these
customers and i thought that was like
weird
yeah and then i was like about a cried
i'm like you know what i quit
my mum was so pissed off at me she was
like you have like because i'd actually
been accepted for the other job
yeah i had a whole like a month and a
half left before i start the other job
she's like i can't believe you quit a
month and a half before your next job
connor like that's really like what the
[ __ ] and i was like mom you don't
understand
how awful this was mcdonald's yeah and
and like she was just chewing me out in
front of these customers and like i was
just like
i don't i'm not being paid enough to be
humiliated in front of these random
people
right like i don't i don't come on man
like i i'm
so [ __ ] young did you smile the
entire time no i was like i was like i
was just sitting there like
okay smile is he getting ready and as
she was just doing i'm like all right
you know what [ __ ] it i quit like i quit
i'm done i'm done like i'm not doing
this i'll finish this shift but i'm done
afterwards
i'm not doing this yeah i never heard
from them again and then uh
yeah i went there like three years later
after i'd like been killing it on
youtube
and then the manager the one who's a
[ __ ] was like what are you doing now
connor i'm like
well wouldn't you want to know well you
know i just got back from la
you know i went to visit my friends in
japan you know i was just making you
know
you know i work one i want make my own
houses you know it's great you know
you should have just been like oh i eat
a burger king pretty regularly
just fill my tax return damn did you
know the tax rate's so high when you
earn so much money
dude damn that [ __ ] that hurts man i'm
sure okay anyway can i have a big flurry
i mean some of them were nice but yeah
everyone was an [ __ ]